the next question from the brother in
the re yeah this is the question for a
non-muslim brother my name is sufyan and
his name is anit Salam alikum he have
one question which is divided into two
parts he was about to become a Muslim he
took a step back he told that as a Hindu
Muslim also have a cast like you are
divided into Shia bori Sunni
jamati and he have a second question
that he can go to the graves kaban and
he can ask from them as they are the
mediator between him and Allah brother
ask the question that one of his Hindu
friend was about to accept Islam he took
a step back thinking that even Islam
there are sect like how they have in
Hinduism in Islam they have got sect
Shia Sunni Jama islami
had brother you read the Quran there's
no Shia Sunni in the Quran there's no
Shia Sunni there's no Jam islami there's
no in the
[Applause]
Quran what does the Quran say Quran says
inah Imran chapter number three verse
Number
103 hold to the Rope of Allah strongly
and be not divided the Rope of Allah is
the Glorious Quran we have to hold to
the Glorious Quran and the authentic
Hadith of Muhammad sah Ali wasallam and
be not divided and it's clearly mention
mention in the Quran in Surah Anam
chapter number 6 verse number
159 where Allah says he say to the
prophet that oh Prophet if anyone makes
divisions sex in the religion of Islam
you have nothing to do with him Allah
will look after his Affairs on the day
of judgment so making sex in Islam is
Haram it is
prohibited what was a beloved Prophet
was he Shia was he Sunni what was he a
beloved prophet
wasallam you are the Muslim that the
reason when I spoke about the master key
of Surah Imran 3: 64
it that say he bear witness that we are
Muslims bowing our will to Allah so
Muslim is a person who submits his will
to Allah subhana tala so tell your
friend in Islam there is no class system
there is no sect we have to be Muslim
Muslim means someone who submits his
will to almighty
God and anyone who submits the will to
almighty God he is called as a
Muslim and if you have to ask Allah
Allah says in Surah FAA chapter number
one verse number
five they alone we worship they alone we
ask for help Allah says in Surah chapter
number 40 verse number 60 you ask me and
I will answer your prayer so if you want
to ask Allah ask Allah directly that is
the right way and that is the best way
hope that answer the
question yes sister assalamu alaykum
this question is from a non-muslim
sister her name is apurva and she is a
student her question is why are the
Muslims not allowed to sing vand mataram
the sister asked the question that why
are Muslims not allowed to say V
matam before I give the answer this is a
common question why are Muslim not
allowed to say V matam which was even
asked in the press conference beginning
of the conference by the Press media
before answering that I would like to
tell you that even the Hindus even they
should not say V mataram
because if you know the song written by
Bim W mam means I bow down to my
motherland one mam it occurs thce in the
full song and as I mentioned earlier
according to the V it's clearly
mentioned in J chapter number 32 verse
number three
andish chapter number four number
19 of that God there is no pratima there
is no image there is no photograph there
is no picture there is no portrait
there's no sculpture there's no
Idol so where is the question of
worshipping the land so any Hindu who
has knowledge of his Veda will never
agree with vand mataram if he does not
know his scripture he may say it but if
he knows scriptures well there are three
lines three stanzas whenever it says
vand mataram I bow down I worship to my
motherland he is going against his
Veda as far as the Muslims are concerned
there are 12
lines which are against the Quran and
theth
th it says that I bow down to my mother
land which is prohibited in Islam we
only bow to our create Allah subhana wa
tala we
Muslims as long as the law of the land
does not go against the law of the
Creator we are for the country we love
the
country we want want to support the
country we want to upbring the country
if required for the truth we are ready
to die for the country but we are not
ready to worship the
country because we worship only Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
he alone requires to be worshiped and
this land who's the creator of this land
Allah almighty God so why should we
worship the creation worship the Creator
not the creation
and furthermore there are stanzas in
vand matam talking about Divine giving
attributes talking about Lakshmi talking
about Dura all these things they go
against the concept of the Quran that's
the reason and if you go back to history
this became a political issue just a
couple of years back you know it was
written in
1860s or 70s by Bim chadya
it was more of a political
motive and today they want to make a
political gimmick not realizing it is
going against their own
religion this song W mataram is going
against their own religion so my advice
is not only Muslims my advice to the
Hindus is that even you don't say V
mataram yes brother assalam alaykum
uh my name is Leon John and uh firstly
I'd like to thank my friend nurah for
bringing me here and giving me this
opportunity to hear some wonderful
teachings from you now I got two
questions to ask first is what does it
take to be a true
Muslim and the second question is
Muslims pray five times a day why don't
we Catholics and other religions pray
five times a day is there any
explanation for
this brother I have two questions first
is that what does it take to be a Muslim
what the requirement and second is why
do Muslims pray five times Catholics
pray less what the
reason as far as what does it take to be
a Muslim as I mentioned earlier Muslim
means a person who submits the will to
God so if you submit your will to God
and follow the Commandments of God you a
Muslim the number one thing is that you
bear witness that there's no God but
Allah no God but one true almighty God
and you bear witness that Prophet
Muhammad is the servant and the
messenger of this God this is the basic
faith it is a fundamental Creed known as
shahada so once you say this you enter
into the basic fundamental Creed and to
be a good Muslim you should submit your
will to almighty God so if you follow
the Commandments given by almighty God
in the Quran and the teachings of the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
authentic Hadith then you'll be a good
practicing
Muslim as far as the second question is
concerned Why do Muslims pray five times
and we Christians we pray less the
reason is we Muslims Salah is a sort of
programming towards righteousness see
normally people they say pray pray is
not the right translation of
Salah pray means to ask for help
in Oxford dictionary pray means
beseech in Salah we don't merely ask for
help besides asking for help we are
getting guidance from Allah subhana tala
in other religions we only ask for help
in Islam besides asking for help we are
getting guidance from Allah subhana wa
tala for example if the Imam after Sur
faat he recites the verse of the Quran
of Sur chapter number five verse number
19 oh you believe
most certainly intoxic and
gambling dedication of stones divination
of
arrows these are Satan's
handwork abstain from this handwork that
you may Prosper here we are getting
guidance from Allah subhana tala in our
Salah that don't have intoxicants don't
gamble don't do fortune telling don't do
idol worship these are sat hand work
abstain from it that you may Prosper so
besides asking for help besides asking
we are getting guidance from Allah
subhana tala and we are thanking Allah
subhana tala so I prefer calling Salah
as programming towards
righteousness and if you analyze today
the amount of evil we see around
us you know bad things happening evil
thing obscenity
cheating there are high chances that we
can get
deprogrammed how a doctor tells you for
a healthy body three meals a day so our
creator almighty God knows that we have
to be programmed five times a
day so that we will be on the straight
track so he's our creator he knows that
so if you are true Christian even you
should offer five times you know why
because if you read your scriptures the
book of Acts like how we do Evolution
Sur ma chter 5 verse number five that
you have to wash your hands wash your
face rub the head with water and wash
the feet up to ankle similarly is
mentioned in the book of Acts similarly
in the book of Exodus that Aaron and
Moses they washed their face and hands
before they appear in front of the Lord
same thing the basic part of s theud if
you Genesis chapter number 17 verse
number three it says that Abraham fell
on his face and prayed to God in Numbers
Chapter number 20 verse number six Aaron
and Moses they fell on their face and
prayed to God Joshua chapter number 5
verse number 14 Joshua fell on his face
and prayed to God if you read the gospel
of Matthew chapter number 26 that Jesus
Christ peace be upon him in the Garden
of Gethsemane he took a few steps
forward and fell on his face and pray to
God can an acrobat fall on his face and
pray to God better than the way we
Muslims do when you do suud we put the
highest part of the body the for on the
lowest part of the ground and say glory
be to Allah the most high glory be to
Allah the most high thri so all the
prophets of the Bible they prayed the
same way as we Muslims pray and Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said in the
Gospel of John chapter number 16 verse
number 12- 14 I have many things to say
unto you but he cannot bear them now for
he when the spirit of truth shall come
he shall guide you unto all truth he
shall not speak of himself all that year
shall he speak he shall glorify me now
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said that
wait for the spirit of Truth talking
about Muhammad peace be upon him and
there are various references of prophet
Muhammad's peace be upon him in the Old
Testament as well as the New Testament
if you read the New Testament in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 18
verse number 18 in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 18 verse
number 19 in the book of Isaiah CH 29
verse number 12 in the Song of Solomon
Chapter number 5 verse number 16 all of
these references speak about the coming
of the last and final messenger Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him even in the
New Testament Gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number 16 Gospel of John
chapter number 15 verse number 26 Gospel
of John chapter number 16 verse number 7
Gospel of John chapter number 16 verse
number 12- 14 all of these references
speak about the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him so if
you're a true Christian if Christian
means a person who follows the teachings
of Jesus Christ peace be upon him we
Muslims are more Christian than the
Christian themselves if you're a true
Christian you have to follow the
teachings of prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and do ablution before Salah
you should do fud and you should pray
five times a day hope that answers the
question thank you I appreciate that
thank you brother Leon for your
questions the next question from the
brother in the
rare sir I'm having a question this
question is Being Framed by my professor
I I am a student of first year computer
science and my sir is teaching me
physics his name is Rajiv B and I am
from NG achara DK marate College chmu he
is convinced by all the I mean to say
what what misconceptions regarding Islam
was there he's accepted that it is not a
misconception so he is not only
convinced by was last point that is
ruthlessly killing of a good during Bak
if you heard your question correctly
your Prophet wants to know that can we
have nonv from the Hindu scripture
that's your question I mean to say the
ruthless killing of a goat the ruthless
kill he believes that you are killing a
goat directly from the slowly slowly
from from the neck brother asked the
question why ruthlessly killing he
agrees with killing of the goat but why
ruthless killing is his question yeah
fine so he's convinced that you can have
nonv but he asking why do the Muslims
they torture the animal before killing
yeah there one J the animal dies why
this Zab slowly
torturing there was a discussion a
similar discuss discussion going on
between a sick and a Muslim and the sick
read the same question you Muslims you
are merciless you are ruthless you all
kill the animal slowly and torture the
animal to death we sick one J F and the
animal dies so the Muslim
replied no we Muslims we are M we attack
from the front we are Mas you think you
all are coward you are buzil you attack
from
behind anyway this is not the real
reason why we Muslim to Z this was his
wisdom hisma this is not the real reason
why we Muslim to Zab the reason we
Muslim do Zab that Islamic slaughtering
is when we do Zab we cut the
throat and the vessels of the neck and
the wind
pipe without damaging the spinal cord
because if the spinal cord is damaged
then there'll be cardiac arrest and the
nerve going to the heart will be severed
and the blood will immediately stagnate
now when we cut the throat and the wind
pipe and the vessel of the neck without
damaging spinal cord The Heart Is Yet
pumping and majority of the blood it
flows out of the body today science
tells us that blood is a very good media
of germs and bacteria so we Muslims we
are hygienic we want to let the blood
flow out of the body when the blood
flows out of the body even the toxin
and the germs and the bacteria that
contain in the blood flow out of the
body there are less chances of having
diseases when we have that meat
furthermore when we cut the throat and
the wind pipe and the vessels of the
neck the nerve which is responsible for
feeling of the pain going to the brain
is also severe so the animal does not
feel pain the animal kicks and rs it is
due to the gush of the flow of the blood
outside the body the kicking and ring is
not due to pain it is due to the muscle
contraction and relaxation so the animal
dies a peaceful death in the method of
stunning very often the animal dies a
painful death after us so the Islamic
method of slaughtering is far more
Humane and furthermore if you Slaughter
the Animal by the Islamic zabia method
the mutton and the meat remains fresh
for a longer time because it does not
have blood hope answer the question
brother yes sister Alum I'm asking this
question on behalf of my friend who is a
Hindu his name is Sachin and is an actor
by profession he would like to know why
Muslim women are not allowed in the
kabristan OR graveyard and if it is the
grave that women are not allowed to
visit then does that include the Dara
has the question that why aren't women
women allowed to visit the graveyard and
there are various different Hadith there
had inkari in which the prophet said he
prevented the wom from going to the
grave and the reasons may be many
because maybe they are very emotional
and they may not be able to take the
death of a human being that's one of the
reasons and furthermore there are other
occasions in which the prophet said that
these women are not allowed because of
the Deeds
that mean restricted certain women
because of their deeds so this is the
reason why women are not permitted into
the grave though there are Scholars
other Scholars who do say that there are
different Hadi in which the prophet did
permit certain women to go depending
upon the context as far as a question is
concerned that about the grave the
Beloved Prophet M sallahu Ali wasallam
said that a person should visit the
grave it will remind you of your AK
that means it reminds you that finally
you have to die but when you go to the
Grave you should pray for the person not
to the person or through the person hope
that answer the
question yes brother your name and
profession and your question my name is
Kar and this is my friend nazish my
question to you Mr naak is that the the
laws that govern the universe uh have
not changed from the time the universe
was created uh they were always there
since since the creation of the universe
so does God have any choice in changing
the laws of the universe since time
immoral why hasn't uh God not change the
laws which governs the universe if the
God has no choice in changing the laws
of the universe then why call him God
the brother asked a good question that
the laws of the universe have been same
since the time it has been formed so
does God have a choice of changing the
laws or not and if God does not have a
choice then why God agree with you it is
God's choice that he does not want to
change that the reason he hasn't
changeed he should not follow your
choice so it is God's will that he does
not want to change now you are forcing
him to change why should he follow you
if God wants to change he can easily
change but Allah says in the Quran in
Surah Room chapter number 30 verse
number 30 that follows the nature of the
law so this is God's
law if he wants he can change but
doesn't want to change that's his choice
now you will tell him that okay that God
he wants to make the sun rise from the
east and set in the
west the challenge is you can you make
the sun rise from the west and set in
the east the answer is no but on the day
of K one of the signs of K is that the
sun will rise from the West to show that
if God wants he can do it so on the day
of
judgment that will happen how will it
happen Allah so Quran says clearly in
Surah fter 35 verse number one that
Allah has power over all things that he
has power all things but Allah does
things which he wants and he does Godly
things hope that answer the question
brother thank you yes any non-muslim
brother there alamu alaykum brother I'm
asking this question on behal my very
close friend he's a non-muslim he don't
want to disclose his name but he's a an
engineer by profession he want to know
Quran does not contradict with modern
science but it says Adam alisam was the
first man on the face of the Earth but
this goes against the theory of Charles
darving regarding
Evolution brother as the question he
says Quran matches with science but does
not agree with the St of the Quran that
Adam is the first human being it goes
against the theory of char dwin and
agree with you the Quran does not agree
with the theory of Charles dwin because
Charles dwin is the theory Quran is a
book of fact not a book of
theory
and if you read the book of Charles
Darwin if you read the book of Charles
Darwin the Origin of Species it says
that Charles Darwin went on the ship by
the name of HMS Beagle which went on
Island by the name of Copus and and he
saw birds pecking in holes and niches
depending upon the niches the bird
pecked the beak became small and long
based on this observation he propounded
his theory of natural selection but he
wrote a letter to his friend Thomas
thomton saying that I have got no 100%
proof regarding my theory but because it
helps me in embryology in rudimentary
organs Etc he has propounded that
otherwise Charles D himself agreed that
they will missing Lings that the reason
in school if we had to insult someone we
used to say that if you were present
during Char's D in time then his theory
would have been proved right insinuating
looks like an
ape so this is just a theory it is not a
fact at all I have not come across a
single book which is called as the fact
of evolution all of these are theories
of evolution and
furthermore according to PP gra he says
it is letting our imagination run too
wild just based on few vestages that we
assuming that we have been evolved from
apes today science has found four waves
first is ticus from the Ice Age then
chromagnon nander told man all these
what science has found there's no link
between them and there's no proof that
we have been evolved from
ape and according to hansis Craig who's
an expert in in molecular
biology he says it is absurd just based
on DNA to assume that our forefathers
were Apes it is just an assumption there
are hundreds of scientists who have
written against Darwin's theory Darwin's
theory has been proved for long ago now
something is come on the internet
recently okay D the these are just
hypothesis but certain things of Darwin
that life has been evolved from water no
problem Quran says that in Sur Amia
chapter number 21 vers number 30 so
certain things are correct but as a
whole that human beings have been
derived from a is unscientific it's a
theory and that's not a fact hope that
answer the
question any sister asalam alikum
brother this is a question from a
non-muslim audience her question states
that we see on television many women
being tortured in Afghanistan why do
Muslim men torture or degrade women in
Islam sister asked the question that we
see on the television you know that
Afghanistan Muslim men are torturing
women so why in Islam Muslim men torture
and degrade the women sister this
question was replied just a few days
earlier on the second day of the
conference on Saturday on Saturday 31st
of October I gave a talk women in Islam
protected or subjugated and I gave the
talk in detail so ask your friend to
watch the that tape watch the DVD
inshallah it will answer all the queries
regarding your main point that she saw
on the
television that in Afghanistan Muslim
men they are beating the
women and once when I was traveling I
came across a Malaysian couple both of
them were doctors they said that they
spent more than a month in
Afghanistan and they told me that what
they saw on television the Taliban
beating the wom they aren't
talibans so I asked them how do you know
they told me that we have being in
Afghanistan we have spent more than a
month we know how the Taliban tied the
turban you know when we see an Arab we
feel all Arabs the same amirati Saudi
Kuwaiti but they themselves know that
are Saudi ties the Katra in a different
way and amirati ties in a different
style if you go to a Kuwaiti different
style so similarly the talibans they
have a particular style of time the ter
so what she told and what he told the
couple that what they
shot even that they didn't do
properly that means they could shoot The
Parting of the sea in Hollywood you know
Ten Commandments Moses peace be upon Him
parting of the sea but they made a fault
when they show Muslim men in Afghanistan
beating the wom so therefore the Quran
says in Surah huat chapter number 49
verse number 6 whenever you get
information you check it up before you
pass it on to the third person what we
realize this this is the gimmick of the
media and in the last conference 2008 my
last talk was media and Islam war of
peace and I showed how the media goes
out of the way to Mal Islam I'm not
saying all Muslims are 100% good Muslims
there are black sheeps in the community
but what the media does picks up these
black sheep and portray as though
they're Exemplar Muslims and many a time
they show things which are absolutely
nonsense it does not exist in Islam so
ask your friend to watch my tape women's
rights in Islam protected or subjugated
and media in Islam war of peace hope
that answerers the question yes brother
my name is v
s I am doing research on this subject of
a spiritual science
Aura one Muslim lady I have treated for
breast cancer she was operated for one
breast right side breast in tata
hospital and second time she got breast
cancer in the left breast and when I
take photograph of that lady I came to
know about the Sal that was present
animal Soul what nonv you are eating
animal soul you can visualize in the
shape of that animal only so this is a
energy and electromagnetic energy of any
kind is a root cause of 99% of health
problem say mobile how much mobile is
danger to kill 100 CR people of India
the mobile itself is a sufficient and
government doesn't know Medical Science
doesn't know the science of spiritual
science of invisible energy that is
electromagnetic energy any electricity
brother brother Dr Zakir is a medical
and a science student what I would
suggest let us keep aside the background
ask your question rather eating a nonv
it is a process which is prescribed how
to cut the animal so if it is cut it One
S the soul goes out energy goes out and
you don't get any health problem from
that M but if it is not cut properly and
it is way it is cut the energy remain in
that meat and you don't know when you
are going to get that type of meat if is
cut in a j and it is cut in a factory
then it will Souls goes out there is no
harm in taking that meat but if it is
not cut properly then you are going to
get cancer paralysis attack and this is
happening what I have observed for 10
years with the photograph now there is
each and every topic
answer will I answer Brothers asked a
question saying that there was a Muslim
woman
and he cured breast cancer then she got
in the other left breast and she cured
the cancer and then he went on to say
that the animal if is killed immediately
the soul goes out no problem if animal
feel ruthlessly it remains and there's a
problem and cancer comes in
short brother I'm requesting you again
why don't you join the Tata Memorial
Hospital of
cancer I know the doctor is there yes I
can tell
you government has made a law drugs and
Magic remedy act
1954 which says that so many disease can
not be Cur you cannot claim for the
disease and that is 99% now I think
brother I haven't answered your question
there's 5 minutes left we have to give
other people a chance and answer your
question government is rightly not
giving you permission because we don't
want to have more problem in the
hospital what do you have to do yes
medical if you can cure cancer why are
you standing here you will get the Nobel
Prize medical science is 4 price for SS
if you can cure cancer and cure the
diseases just by spiritual thing then
I'll ask the Nobel committee to give you
the Nobel Prize but but the committee
will never select you I'll tell you why
I gave such a scientific reason why
Muslims Slaughter the animal and let the
blood flow out yet you're saying that
the soul remains and the Soul goes out
you'll have cancer brother your medical
knowledge is so
weak student to science tells us that
blood is a good medium of bacteria and
germs and toxin if we Slaughter the
Islamic way the blood glows out and the
toxin goes out there's less chance of
having disease you are saying the
opposite now which science you're
talking about I don't know I a medical
doctor I have got an mbbs degree and
Quran says in Surah n chapter 16 verse
43 and Surah Amia chapter number 21
verse number
7 if you you don't know ask the person
who knows so this is my speciality you
can very well do what you want the way
you want to practice but I'm giving a
scientific reason why we do it and that
is the reason the Islamic method is far
superior and it is much more hygienic
and the meat remains fresh for a longer
time hope that answer the question any
sister this is on behalf of a non-muslim
sister yes that would be the last
question of the day please her question
is what is the major difference between
prophet Jesus and Prophet Muhammad if
Prophet Jesus teaches people how to live
life and worship God the same thing is
taught by Prophet Muhammad those who are
following Jesus are they correct or
should they follow the instructions of
prophet Muhammad because Prophet Jesus
may come again on this Earth so he could
be the last prophet this the last very
good question she asked the question
what is the difference between prophet
Jesus and Prophet Muhammad if both of
them taught good things to worship the
same God what's the difference who
should we follow and Prophet Jesus is
going to come again so he will be the
last prophet as far as the question is
concerned that amongst all the prophets
five prophets are considered according
to the Hadith as great
prophets Prophet
Ibrahim Prophet new Alam Prophet Moses
Prophet Jesus and and Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him so we consider Jesus
Christ peace be upon him as one of the
mightiest messengers of Allah subhana
tala before I answer the question I you
one thing that no muslim is a Muslim if
he does not believe in Jesus Christ
peace be upon him we believe that he was
one of the mightiest messengers of God
we believe that he was the Messiah
translated Christ we believe that he was
born miraculously without any male
Intervention which many modern day
Christians today do not believe we
believe that that he gave life to the
Dead with God's permission we believe he
healed those born blind and lepers with
God's permission the Christian and the
Muslims we are going together you may
ask where is The Parting of ways The
Parting of ways is that many
Christians they say that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him he claimed Divinity in
fact if you read the Bible there is not
a single unequivocal statement in the
complete Bible where Jesus Christ peace
be upon him himself says that I am God
or where he say worship me if any
Christian can point out any words of the
Bible any unequivocal statement any
unambiguous statement from the bible
where jesus christ peace be upon him
himself says that I am God or where he
says worship me I'm ready to accept
Christianity in fact if you read the
Bible Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said it's mentioned in the Gospel of
John chapter number 14 verse number 28
my father is greater than I Gospel of
John chapter number 10 verse number 29
my father is greater than All gospel of
Matthew chapter number 12 verse number
28 I with the Finger of God cast out
devil Gospel of Luke chapter 11 verse
number 20 I with the spirit of God cast
out devil Gospel of John chapter number
5 verse number 30 I can of my own self
do nothing as I hear I judge and my
judgment is just for I seek not my will
but the will of my father anyone who
says I seek not my will but the will of
almighty God he's a Muslim Jesus Christ
peace be upon him as a Muslim he never
claimed Divinity it's clearly mentioned
in the Gospel of John chapter number 14
verse number 24 he said that the words
that you hear are not mine but my
fathers who has sent me it's mentioned
in the Gospel of John chapter number 77
verse number three Jesus Christ peace be
upon Him says this is life eternal so
that you may know there is one God and
Jesus Christ whom thou has sent it's
clearly mention in the book of Acts
chapter number two verse number
22 e men of Israel listen to this Jesus
of Nazareth a man approved of God
amongst You by wonders and miracles and
signs which God did by him and you
witnessed to
it a man approved of God amongst You by
wonders and miracles and signs which God
did by men you witness to it so Jesus
Christ peace be upon him was one of the
mightiest messengers of God but he was
not God and if you want to follow him as
I mentioned earlier in Gospel of John
chapter number 16 verse number 12- 14 he
said as have many things to say unto you
but he cannot bear them now for he when
the spirit of truth shall come he shall
guide you unto all Tru that means if you
are a true follow of Jesus Christ peace
be upon him besides believing in one God
you also have to follow the last and
final messenger Prophet Muhammad's peace
be upon him as far as the last question
is
concerned that he will come again so
isn't he the last prophet it's mentioned
in the Quran in Surah MAA chapter number
5 verse number 116 that Jesus Christ
peace be upon himself to Allah subhana
tala that he bear witness I never said
worship me but I said worship
Allah who's my Lord and your lord so he
will come in the second coming why he's
the only messenger of God whose
followers as a whole mistook that he
claimed Divinity all the other
Messengers none of their followers
mistook that they claimed Divinity isaam
Jesus Christ peace be upon Him is the
only messenger whose followers had a
miss understanding that he claimed
Divinity that the reason in his second
coming he will come as a follower of
Muhammad sallallahu Alam he will not
bring any new teaching he will come to
testify that he never claimed Divinity
he will not bring any new message the
message is complete Quran says in Surah
MAA 5 verse number three this day have
we perfected our religion for you and
have chosen for you Islam and I've
completed my favor on you so nothing new
can be added or subtracted from Islam
Isa Alam many second coming he will come
to testify to the Christians he never
said worship me
but worship
Allah who's my Lord and your lord so he
will come as an umat of mammad sallu Ali
wasallam to clarify the misconception
among the Christians hope to answer the
question Dr Zak we apologize for those
who didn't get a chance inshallah this
session will continue tomorrow so much
so that we'll have no lecture of Dr
Zakir your challenging questions
can be asked in an exclusive open
question answer session called ask Dr
Zakir inshallah it will start with theat
by sh Salah Al IM Majid Ali tomorrow
same place same open ground 6:20 p.m.
before that of course we will have the
morning sessions to as per the program
scheduled
e for